there's a rumor going around the
business the show business that you
FaceTime with Oprah and Maria Shriver
is that true yeah Maria Shriver started
this fun thing where she just calls
people like around six o'clock friends
and she's like let's let's do FaceTime
and I'll bring him fun guests surprise
fun guest I'm like great comedy and so
it was just me Scottie and Maria no
problem we just had a really good time
and then you know did I lose you
yeah none and then well we chatted about
the current events and it was fun I mean
but wait Oprah joins you okay joint
that's insane
that's that's not something that most
people can relate to well well
me and you were talking right now why
would Noah and I be talking or over and
you you're right
butor I'm saying for a second I forgot
my cell Conan Oh Sean I had no idea it
was you I took mine off for clarity and
you put yours on yeah I yeah I'm gonna
pretend that that would be no big deal
for me to talk to Oprah well of course
you're like oh my gosh Maria why didn't
you tell me was Oprah and then and then
but then you talked to Oprah for five
minutes you realize Oprah's Oprah
because she's completely of the earth
yeah like she's grounded and regular and
fun and easygoing and smart and all
those things that she omits there's a
the news that she's quarantined Stedman
is that right has Stedman in quarantine
I think the story is that she
quarantined Stedman but starting six
years ago that's what I've heard this
story is that Stedman was traveling I
think and you know Oprah had just gotten
over from being sick and so she was very
scared so yeah okay don't worry none of
that's going in